je rentre à la maison je dépose en
dessous du boulot parce que je finissais
plutôt voilà et soit ma moto je roule
tranquillement normalement c'est une
sportive que j'aime et je suis pas
imposé en position attaque parce que
j'aurais pu être en position attaquée
accéder partout tout le temps mais ce
n'est pas à mon ça n'a pas été mon cas
je roule tranquillement je me faufile
tranquillement d' abîmer le véhicule
l'image il m'a heurté j'ai même pas vu
comment je suis monté
j'ai été éjecté et je suis tombé tout de
suite sur le dos je ne comprends pas ce
qui m'arrive parce que je me retrouve
par terre et et en quelques secondes
même pas deux secondes j'étais déjà il
m'a tapée j'étais déjà étalés par terre
sur le dos
subitement j'ai eu très mal c'est même
pas une sensation de mal si on a j'ai eu
la sensation d'avoir mal j'avais
tellement mal que j'ai réalisé même pas
comme si on a envie de pleurer mais
j'avais pas les lampes qui sortait et
j'arrive et je regardais mes pieds ça
mais je lui il me demandait si
j'arrivais à bouger mais si jamais j'en
arrivais pas j'ai forcé mais je
n'arrivais pas à les bouger mais on a un
tout qui qui qui vous fait mal et où
vous n'avez même pas exprimer cette
souffrance voilà
c'est une paraplégie incomplète ça fait
neuf mois déjà là et la dcri c'est comme
si j'ai des pieds dans du ciment dans
les deux sens mais elle pèse deux tonnes
à peu près on va dire ouais deux tonnes
et des gens mais pas ceux de tout c'est
comme si j'ai j'ai des potes avec du
ciment là dedans et j'arrive pas bougé
comme je veux voilà c'est ça le prouver
il ça m'a changé ma vie et je ne suis
pas content mais je suis pas content au
début je n'étais pas content parce que
c'est depuis en fauteuil roulant
handicapés on appelle son handicap est
pas adapté pas adapté 2d vous poser une
question pas adapté pas adapté les bus
pas adapté pas adapté donc après c est
difficile il ya tout de suite d d d d
obstacles j'ai pas dit que j'accepte
cette situation a pour l'instant mais
c'est trop
je peut qu'avancer parce que je suis
tout seul dans ma mère donneront de ma
situation
est-ce que je suis
une victime de la route et que ça m'a un
peu ça va un peu intéressés ça m'a
sensibilisé parce que moi je j'ai été
fauché par une personne qui qui m'a pas
vu voilà il ya qui m'a pas vu dans son
rétroviseur voilà c'est à cause de ça
que j'ai accepté parce que je fais je
suis là dedans je suis comme un acteur
jeune acteur delà de la sécurité
routière voilà donc ça serait bien de
faire savoir aux gens qu'il faut
contrôler rétroviseur on va dire la
personne qui m'a fauché mais n'avait pas
bien fait ces contrôles je serais pas
ici à vous parler maintenant